the US Navy says it is assisting after
an apparent attack on two tankers in the
Middle East a US defense official tell
CBS News Iran is likely behind the
attack pictures released by Iranian
state media show smoke billowing from
the ships the incident took place
overnight near the Strait of Hormuz the
main artery for transporting oil from
the Middle East global oil prices are
rising this morning MTS ty AB is Munna
Turing developments from London MT as
what do we know about this attack good
morning yeah those simmering tensions in
the Gulf are back to boiling after what
appears to be two serious assaults on
tankers take a look at these pictures
from Iranian state media which claim to
show the aftermath of these alleged
assaults now the Japanese firm that owns
one of the tankers says it ship was and
I'm quoting here shelled at least twice
setting fire to the engine room forcing
its crew to abandon ship a second vessel
a Norwegian vessel was struck with what
its managers are describing as a quote
torpedo now that ship is said to be
adrift and on fire both crews have
reportedly been rescued now the u.s. 5th
fleet based in Bahrain has confirmed it
received two distress signals but did
not say how the vessels were attacked or
who was behind it of his latest
incidents come just a month after four
oil tankers were attacked off the coast
of the UAE Washington accuses Tehran of
orchestrating those in it those attacks
and accusation it denies now the timing
of today's incident is sensitive japan's
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a is in the
Iranian capital on a high-stakes
diplomacy mission where he warned that
tensions between the u.s. and Iran could
lead to what he called an accidental
comfort this morning on Twitter the
Iranian Foreign Minister called those
talks friendly but he added suspicious
doesn't begin to describe what likely
transpired this morning now just
underscore the ripple effect these
tensions and the Gulf have around the
world the price of oil has already
spiked
the main concern is that all of this
could boil over into something far more
serious Tony MTS thank you